rochefort sur mer
une place qui a l'air tranquille
et pourtant les maisons ont des couleurs
pastel et volé son jaune vert violet ou
framboises
jacques demy en effet il tourne les
demoiselles de rochefort sur une musique
de son inséparable ami michel legrand à
qui l'on doit également celle des
parapluies de cherbourg
vedette de cette nouvelle comédie
musicale gene kelly
george chakiris le héros de west side
story
danielle darrieux michel piccoli jacques
perrin et françoise dorléac et catherine
donald soeur dans la vie françoise et
catherine deviennent jumelles dans ce
film l'une est professeur de solfège
l'autre professeur de danse
jacques demy pourquoi rochefort c'est
vrai tout à fait par hasard
oui d'abord la découverte de la ville
comme ça j'ai vu beaucoup de villes dans
le sud pendant ce temps la cote ni
carnet m je fais de nice à perpignan
effet une très grande place très
architecturé je viens comme comme et
rochefort justement et j'ai trouvé
rochefort après je suis retourné sur la
côte d'azur et finalement je suis revenu
rochefort au moment des parapluies de
cherbourg de jacques demy vous vouliez
définir votre film comme un film jazz ce
que l'on peut dire la même chose pour
moi zèle de rochefort oui mais alors
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
à passer d'une comédie musicale mais je
ne fais pas sur la musique je le fais
sur le sentiment sur l'assentiment de la
vie sur un sentiment de joie décidé de
capter cette espèce de bonheur comme ça
d'être dit son sein vivant
dire comme ça en bonne santé joyeux et
communiquer cette espèce de joie les la
rend plus urgent est la danse qui permet
directement l'explosion de
chaker je sais pas il semble que là
c'est sur ce plan là vous entendez bien
pourquoi le mondial là encore ce sont
des l'habitude de vivre ensemble l'année
qui vise 7 ans en visite à ensemble mais
je crois que c'est à françois nom
catherine que vous devez l'avoir fait du
cinéma
oui c'est exact et quelqu'un ne m'en
veut on se séparera compris et bien je
tournais je devais tourner les portes
claquent et dans le film j'ai besoin
d'une soeur et le producteur francis
faune m'a demandé si on cassait pas
quelqu'un qui me rassure mais beaucoup à
j-6 une somme beaucoup plus encore enfin
assez et c'est comme ça que catherine a
commenté ainsi les marches et elle n'est
pas content d'ailleurs elle l'a fait
parce que c'était les vacances des
grandes vacances sont guère poussés ont
été poussés dans le supporter elle
s'appelle déjà
ça vous manque pas par exemple d'avoir
pas fait comme françoise de
conservatoire d'avoir du hsv
nous sommes deux
l'ifac de l'avenir et rémy passage
sonnerait donc soutenu demoiselle ayant
eu des amants très tôt il va cela
m'irait rémy pas qu'un seul rideau